it's a a british-born influencer
isn't it he's a social media guy who uh
just went
viral after completing his 18th
plastic surgery to look like a member of
the korean pop band
bts uh this man now
his name is ali london he also uses
plural pronouns
that's like the 17th strangest thing
about this story
he now identifies as
korean and he he shared his his new
self-identity journey
on social media i identify as korean
that's just my culture that's my home
country
that's exactly how i look now um
and i also identify as jimmy and that's
my career name but uh
not only that i just i know it's a
little bit confusing for some people
nobody's ever come out as jimin or
korean but um
this is something that you guys know if
you've followed my journey for the last
eight years i've really struggled with
identity issues
he's really struggled with identity
issues and now he's korean
some people are saying he's just doing
this for attention well i guess he's he
does everything for attention because
he's a social media influencer
but he's clearly got got something going
on here in his head he's had 18
surgeries to do this
and people are really upset on the left
about this and people are really
befuddled on the right about this
but the fact is this british dude
identifying as korean
makes much more sense than
transgenderism
it is much more believable that a white
guy
can become a korean guy than that any
kind of guy
can become any kind of woman because
race
is much less important to identity
than sex the fundamental distinction
among people is sex
the sexes are complementary they
together
form the fundamental political unit the
family
they got different potty parts to do
different things and together they make
babies
the races have differences there's no
question
much less distinct much less important
and the left is very upset about this
because they've identified racism as the
as the worst possible sin they've kind
of redefined all sin as just
racism and especially if a white person
does anything to appropriate a culture
of another right if
if a white person enjoys the culture of
other people
that's called appropriation if a white
person doesn't care about the culture
of other people that's called erasure so
the white guy can't do anything right
anything he does with regard to race or
culture is considered wrong and evil and
bigoted
but this makes much more sense now of
course the guy
is not really korean and of course the
man who thinks he's a woman is not
really a woman
but if you accept the logic of
transgenderism you you certainly must
accept that this guy is korean he's
obviously got identity issues we've all
got identity issues these days
this is i think because of the deeply
religious confusion of our society and
the question of what human nature really
is
but that question of who are we is is
now being accelerated
by the courts by the establishment which
is buying into these delusions
hey i'm glad you love that clip there's
a whole episode called the nfl is gay
that's true don't take me off youtube
that she can't be hate speech because
the nfl said it itself
don't don't take me off they're gonna
try to take me off head on over there
subscribe
like leave a comment and most
importantly of all you can order my book
speechless controlling words controlling
lines it's available
now it's now available for order go
check it out today see you next time
[Music]
you